hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute ist es endlich soweit um
19.05 kommt ein richtig cooler galileo
beitrag über mich auf prosieben
da freue ich mich wenn ihr alle
einschaltet also ich hab mir habe ich
schon ganz lange auf diesen tag gefreut
und heute ist es endlich soweit und es
ganz besondere ist nach diesem 15
minütigen beitrag auf galileo eben im
fernseher kommt noch ein live backen mit
mir zusammen und zwar auf galileo punkt
tv das heißt im internet könnte im
online stream das dann mit verfolgen und
sogar live mit backen denn auf der
galileo facebook seite und auch auf der
homepage wurde schon das rezept
veröffentlicht also praktisch die
zutaten
ihr braucht dafür einfach etwas nutella
gebraucht bis 12 eier dann braucht ihr
noch ganz viel obst also so paar früchte
kiwis erdbeeren
egal was ihr eben da habt und am besten
holt ihr euch noch etwas frischkäse
mascarpone oder quark oder auch
entspannt und ich denke das war's
eigentlich im prinzip schon eine
warntafel weiße schokolade und dann
verrate ich euch heute abend natürlich
erst was wir zusammen machen wenn ihr
das also noch nicht zu hause hat bis
jetzt noch schnell einkaufen gehen und
das alles besorgen damit wir auch
wirklich zusammen backen können
ich weiß nicht für murat mitmachen darf
auf prosieben zu sehen möchte meine
shows ich muss es ist wir sind gespannt
ob er mitmachen darf
was sind wir schon richtig vorbereitet
und das team ist auch jeden augenblick
kommen die technik muss er hier
aufgebaut werden
und es ist schon ziemlich aufregend für
mich jetzt vor allem live hallo
man kann wenn es herausschneiden und ja
das ist das eine das andere ist morgen
kommt endlich mein video über den
kitchenette blender
das video habe ich euch ja schon länger
versprochen viele wissen dass ich den
schon länger etc stehen habe und auch in
gebrauchter proteste steht ihr immer im
hintergrund und das kommt morgen dann
kommt noch die verlosung denn ihr habt
ihr alle fleißig für mich abgestimmt
vielen dank dafür ich habe beim
philadelphia contest eben also meine
tochter hat gewonnen wurde eben als
ästhet orte ausgewählt und ich hab die
drei kitchenette produkte gewonnen und
darf die jetzt eben an euch
verlosen und marken kommt da eben das
video dazu gemeinsam mit dem blender
video
da werde ich euch dann alle
informationen geben wie ihr das gewinnen
könnt und ja da freue ich mich schon
richtig drauf jetzt bin ich noch ein
bisschen aufgeregt und ich hab ich mit
tee oder irgendwas trinken dass ich
wieder runterkommt muss ich noch ein
bisschen hübsch machen und dann was ich
morath doch ich bin aufgeregt ich bin
auch noch einmal nötig weil die galerie
zuschauer riesig dass ich schwanger sei
es werden auszudrücken nicht so viel
torte gegessen
na ja auf jeden fall ich freue mich echt
schon und hoffe dass eben nicht alle
heute abend unterstützt und am sonntag
bei nacht und am sonntag kommt eine
regenbogen torte die heute der stadt
verratet der chor am sonntag kommt mit
einer torte
ich mache mir meine mutter mache
aussetzt tempomat cap fonds 7
doch was nach aus